there's different techniques of how to
fall
that's really cool i did not know that
hey welcome back to another episode of
stuntman react we are here with the
famous and infamous gita silva welcome
back man good to have you dude yeah yes
you may remember gee from the past
episodes we've done he uh has doubled
his black panther so you should go check
out gee's stuff if you have not nico and
i pulled some sweet clips for you to
react to to give your expertise and
opinion on let's hop in and take a look
[Music]
all right here we go just know that this
entire shot is one on broken take four
minutes long
you'll see things just noise
you don't have any setup time like
really do that stuff you just gotta do
it because when i'm broken take right
oh
man
man
what if he missed
one twenty job
two minutes
oh my goodness
i love that move just kills the guy
somehow
[Music]
okay japanese guys okay where'd that guy
go there's a crash pad yeah definitely
there was box they had that set up how
big like they got like 12 bounce houses
down there or like
definitely five because he's he's on
story three he's still falling like he
probably goes
they definitely they those guys who got
beat up who aren't running back a
different way to meet him up top are
pulling pads and it's pretty fun
oh jeez he just punched that guy in the
face
just dead guys hell yeah good shot
[Music]
where's my elephant
that's so cool man this is this is very
special the camera's guy and the focus
part was just like don't screw it up
don't screw it up keep them in the frame
how like how did he get up there in the
time though like
at least 20 job man he's like
how long does he have let's see let's
count
he's got one
two
three
four
no
i think he i think he's your dresser
you're right he's the dresser 100
dude that's within like three seconds
though he has [ __ ]
so tell me a little bit more about that
throw that almost missed yeah that's
like probably
one of the scariest things it's up to
how juicy actors feeling at that moment
and it looked like he could have easily
not made it through the middle of that
guess what you're about to go over but
are you ready i'm ready all right here's
the knee all right here we go do you
think they're talking to each other
definitely i would be talking to you and
it's like right here he pauses spot it
you see it i see it all right go i'll
see you later tonight yeah
so they got a pad in that thing right
they like they got some i don't know man
tyler it's thailand bro i've heard
stories that hiring a stuntman is
cheaper than renting a pad in thailand
oh my goodness by the way quick little
bit of trivia if you happen to have the
dvd release of the protector the
original us release and one of the bonus
features
is a short martial arts film that i made
what yeah i won a contest me and my
friend eric lim won a contest awesome oh
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
this is from a movie from 1939 directed
by john ford
um one of the things i love about these
old films because there's no cg
what you see is what's happening they do
have rear projection though
[Music]
wow that's pretty wild this is actually
the inspiration for the raiders of the
lost ark stunt scene which is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is he right there is he underneath the
horse or is he between the two he's
between the two that's why he holds on
he lines himself up right there what's
also funny is like the guy gets shot
twice and dies
and then the camera stays on him and he
thinks he's done with the shot and he
gets up at the end of it he's like i did
it i think he starts getting up you're
supposed to be dead you're supposed to
be dead huh what you're supposed
fine whatever
[Music]
this is the same guy by the way that
went under the horses same stunt man i
mean this is insane because if you fall
you're
dead yeah pardon my french
you can get trampled so the name of the
stone guy was yakima knut and he
actually got an honorary oscar in 1967.
so i guess they did stun oscars a little
bit wow
that's amazing yeah that's really cool i
did not know that
[Music]
oh
that's like the fault that dean took on
his onewheel last week how do those
horses do that they would have a wire
that is connected to the leg of the
horse
and the horse is kind of i guess trained
to the extent of which it can be trained
to be able to take a fall but see how
their their legs are getting pulled
from under them dude
oh it's so bad poor horses man like that
horse wasn't like hey i'm going to be a
stunt horse when i grow up he's able to
get back up
you can't do that kind of stuff to
animals anymore
[Music]
are they are they throwing more dirt
down right there to like pad
[Laughter]
these guys back in the day
these are the dudes that a lot of them
can barely walk because they did
that kind of stuff yeah but there was
also a different tone to when you spoke
to a stunt person or dealt with some
people compared to how it is now back in
that day they were the coolest guys on
set they were like how much do we need
to pay you to do this stunt i heard
stories of that nowadays they've made it
kind of safer for us there's no more
macho madness kind of thing that comes
with being a stunt man that you would
think if you enjoy this show and you
want to make sure you don't miss an
episode please consider subscribing that
way you are not at the whims of the
algorithm but you have taken fate into
your hands and you will not ever miss
another episode of stuntmen react
what movie is this from this is from
project a so jackie's a cop and he's
going in to nab the bad guy but the
hotel's not having it he's like you
can't come in here
[Music]
[Music]
there's no training for that you just do
that on the day so it's a scored chair
right yeah so they pre-cut the chair so
it's gonna be way easier to break
that's the fall that you pad up for and
the thing that hits is the thing that's
not padded
right
my toes right toes her watching this
[Applause]
put them into a skeleton oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
right here
dang
do you think one of these guys broke a
rib in this scene oh yeah absolutely i
broke a rib watching this scene
there's different techniques of how to
fall jackie actually had a movie called
my stunts yes and he kind of displays
every fall that they practice and train
and then once you have i guess the
blueprints then you can mess with the
shapes and add performance to it which
then makes it look as messy as they're
doing it
like this fall right here is a side fall
so if you're landing like sideways like
somebody swept your legs you want to
distribute the energy in as many places
as possible you don't want to go to one
single point
if you were to take a fall and land on
your knee you have a hundred percent of
your energy on your knee but if you were
good if you were to land with as much
contact as possible you got 10 10 10 10
10 percent yes
yeah exactly
that that's fun that's the back fall
that's the assisted backfall see how
he's holding him boom his arms go up the
guy the bob's actually catching me on
the top and then how does he not crush
his chest thanks to yin bio he's
spreading his feet out at the at the
point of impact so he's taking it mostly
on the legs but then
letting them come out if like niko if
you were to do that to me right now i
would probably break your ribs i'd be
out dude i would be out
[Applause]
[Music]
i
he think have laid on his head
i think grabbing the chandelier helped
him because he slowed himself down a
little right a little bit but it also
looks like it's whipping his legs like
he let's go just the right moment to not
break his neck just and just enough to
clear the bar also they could have hit
like a little pad i bet you could have i
hope i love how you have all these uh
hotel clerks they stop and they're like
oh is it good the whole stunt team oh
jerry are you all right
[Applause]
all right this is it oh this is this is
the move this is all the baby powder
whole bottle right there
boom cvs no longer has baby powder
[Laughter]
there's a thing that was told to me by a
great stunt man you want to hit the
ground you don't want the ground to hit
you mm-hmm he's in his mind like i'm
gonna destroy the hell out of that table
i'm an elbow drop macho man randy savage
this table
i'm going through it
nothing to it but to do it
and that's how he was able to not hurt
himself just owned it man we have an
endless supply of jackie chan clips to
go through
if you guys have one that you would like
for us to react to we'll get a
professional down here we'll react to it
leave a comment down below
are you a fan of john woo oh yeah no one
does it like john woo he is two gun
fights with jackie chan as martial arts
yes he is absolutely he's the beauty
he's the ballet of it
oh
man
[Music]
these are the candles these practical
effects are tough
man pay attention to like how
well he intercuts slow motion without
slow motion ever being boring
[Music]
that guy just stepped on his face
what the guy just stepped on that dude's
face dude oh
whoa
this guy just iced so hard oh
it barely broke his fall
[Applause]
so why is this one so visceral compared
to like the dudes falling off the ledges
because it's it's like a stop of energy
here's everything you said not to do in
a fall which is concentrate all your
impact into one point and that guy just
does it there's no other way is there
he definitely sat there for maybe like
five minutes thinking about life
[Music]
oh
oh man shooting a blank that close to
somebody is really sketchy that's sketch
theoretically a clean blank can kill you
there's still a big pressure bubble that
comes out of the gun it can hurt the sun
man if you look closely you can see that
the gun is angled slightly off to the
side so that that big burst of pressure
from the muzzle flash is more going off
to the side of the guy than rather
straight into him it's so close yeah
it's right between the gap on his arm
like before right there these days you
probably wouldn't be able to do this
anxiety levels are really high whenever
i'm dealing with guns on set i i don't
know why but
every time i'm just like okay i'm not
doing anything with this until it's time
to do something with it and other than
that i'd rather you hold it and not me
so i'm civilized
[Music]
yeah there's the hong kong school of
getting shot which is
yep right and then there's the
italian slash classic american school
getting shot which is
good muscle's tightened up hold it
hold it turn away and fall
i've filmed people getting squared or
you know getting shot up but i've never
really been scrimped up myself yeah
that's something i'd really like to
experience i think we should try to
execute that for one of these videos
that should definitely happen yeah if
you guys would like to see that consider
subscribing to the channel so you don't
miss it when it comes i think it's
somewhere like right there
yes yo you guys have ilrom here that
must have been fun it was awesome he's
so cool yeah everyone's really nice guy
i just want to give you a little uh
present here some quarter merch as a
thank you for coming out um we have the
motion capture designed crew neck by the
way all this stuff is restocked uh this
is restocked the green screen blanket is
restocked this sold out like a day the
vfx artist t-shirt is restocked would
you like this yeah here you go
the uh the yellow shatter logo on the
hoodie this is reflective by the way
would you like this sure here you go
yeah thank you we also have backpacks
with the quarter logo these are really
nice backpacks oh and ren come here come
here ren check out these pants rin is
wearing whoa these joggers that's right
stylish jars
back in stock these also sold out in
like a day all this stuff is really high
quality no idea how long it'll last we
only order unlimited quantities and they
tend to sell in a few days so if you
guys are seeing this video when it's
gone live and you want any of this stuff
jump on it right now because it goes
quick
quarter digital dot store link in the
description below thank you everybody so
gee thank you so much for joining us if
you guys would like to check out gee's
stuff uh follow him ask him questions
whatever you'd like to do he's on
instagram at gee ex to silva yeah link
in the description below um you can also
check them out all over youtube the uala
videos by the way
top class hey thank you guys for having
me yeah you bet man thank you so much
for coming out it's good seeing you if
you guys have any awesome stunts or
action scenes that you would love us to
react to we'll bring in a professional
we'll get them to react to it we read
all the comments do it leave a comment
down below wait you guys are calling
professionals you're a professional
you're the pro what you're the problem
i'm probably like amateur you're
literally black panther